Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and - whaaaa - hi!
ah, decrepit. Oh!
Breathey
Alright, so welcome to Madison
Now this is a horror game
that I -
Okay *laughs* know what, whenever I look down a hallway, and I'm filled with a - *gasps*
Okay long story short, I'm not going in there long story long . . What the hell's happening here?
I - I don't know anything about this game other than that it's called Madison, and this is a demo for it
That's locked, okay alright. I'm kinda getting a - *loud thud*
Hi! that's new that wasn't like that before
with the tarp and the picnic blankett
Okay hello. (character speaks) Polaroid: point, shoot, print, and shake
(Mark): Let me get a good look at this, let me really get a sniff on this one. *sniffs loudly* Okay, all right, got it, grabbed it.
What - the - hell - is - happening
Okay got Polaroid
got a breath
*reading from note* This is it notify that your child Luca Maxwell is hereby expelled from Westlake secondary school
*pretending to cry* is it 'cause she's a demon child?
*reading from note* The situation is now dangerous - *creaking noise in background*
Hello?
*reading from note* Boy, who was stabbed went to the police? *Mark gasps*
*reading from note* Pressed charges against your child. *finished reading note*  Oh, oh no my child stabbed someone *chuckles*
Why did my child stab someone? *door closes*
(to door) No.
Okay, all right, just so we're on the same page
Ahh, I don't want to.
*Mark* oo, hey! *character* Fuck. .
*Mark* Hey . . clock!
you shut up.
Shut up, I don't know what you want for me, but shut up and go away
*glasses clanking together*
Clankity clankity you know what I'm not gonna deal with you
I didn't think I was gonna go down here, but it looks like I have to here we go
Squeeeze
*laughs* that's a nice squoze.
Ohhh. this is a tight squeeeeze
Ohh really squizzin' up in here
*mark grunts loudly*
this doesn't look good
Ah, this feels bad.
Ah this feels - *gasps*
Hi. *mark squeals loudly* ohh! A keeey! *squeaking in background*
*laughs sarcastically* Lucky me! *weird noise behind him*
*heavy breathing from character* (mark): hi, hello? hi, hello? hi - woahh!
Sorry, just got jiggly for a second now. Let me just squoooze back here
*laughs and pretends to be struggling* it's a real squinko
Why? who builds a house like this also?
I did that now, glad I did that, never have to do that again. i'm just gonna click and drag that closed there blam! *creaking sound*
Oh, hi.
There's a lot of creaky squeaky's going on in this house and
I don't like that, but I got a key and I can only assume that it's to this
Let's see. hang on. Yep. That looks good. Okay. All right. Let's use it: study key
I'm really trying oh oh
This ain't a study. This is not a study; are you sitting there, was that football helmet. What's going on?
What's happening here?
is that a present for me?
oh grandpa you ain't look so good Madison is that you *something moving in corner of room*
(Mark): hi
All right
Okay, and I seem to be guiding myself into a world of hurt
Let me take a look at grandpa *door closes behind him*
aliright you know what I changed my mind. I don't wanna be here
Hey, Grandpa, how you doing
whoa its color? Oh? Ahaha
Whoa, hi
Why did I stuff that in - you turned? I don't like any of that yeah - hi oh, man
That is an unflattering picture. Albert Meyers. Well, okay. (character): Oh whoa, it's just like dad
(Mark): What you always walk around the beach shirtless with pants? I don't know
Okay, all right, just like dad
Whoa! I don't wanna stick my head in here. I don't wanna, nooo. *pretends to cry*
hi, okay, alright
I hate this! let's not do that. *something creaks*
oooh, okay. *loud music* (mark yells): okay!
Is that Jim News?
(man on tv): In local news, the remaining belongings in the Hell family estate were finally auctioned.
*noise comes from behind Mark* (man on tv): bringing in nearly 3 million dollars.
Among the items were paintings by Picasso as well as some gold and diamond jewelry *tv messes up*
(man on tv):Also worthy, was miss Hell's precious, instant camera, which has finally found a new owner
It's been 30 years since the notorious multiple murders and in spite of numerous auctions of the family assets
No one had previously purchased her camera
for viewers unfamiliar with the story Madison Hell killed her own family during witchcraft ceremony
She was then fatally shot in the stomach by a police officer who had caught her in the act
and now for he weather.
(Mark): And now for the weather? that does sound like a Jim; Darkiplier, was that you?
*mark yelling* I don't know!
Ahhhh!
All right fine *door closes in background* stop being a little bitch, baby
Okay, all right, I'll open this present (character): My-my birthday present?
But how did it get here we?
(Mark): Wait, I'm Lu - *glass smashing*
I'm Luca. Wait, I'm Luca. Wait, I stabbed the kid. Oh, I'm a badass!
Oh, hell yeah - whoa... ah!
That don't look so good; that doesn't look so good at all
Okay whoo
there's a lot of noises coming from over there. Just you wait oh *laughing noises of some sort*
I don't like camera mode, but there's some film over there all right camera mode, yay! Yay, yay, yay!
All righty, let's take a nice picture here boom
Holy shit, what the fuck, shake it ahhhh there we go, that's so - ohhhh
Well, huh that is peculiar
I don't know about that. That's weird, huh
weird. all right
Oh!
*sarcastic tone* noose, great!
awesome!
Polaroids, great!
Ohhhh, great!
Why's it dark? Ahhh, I don't wanna
play this game, I don't wanna play it. I don't want to play it. I do not want to play it *laughter of some sort* oh
How are you? Are you good? There's some missing paintings from there, okay? Ah I don't have a password
Okay, thank you. I can't - I can't do anything okay. All right. I'll come back, later
I'll go into camera mode. Nope that's not ca- there's camera mode
Okay, alrighty then. Ho-
-ly shiit - take a picture boom
Nothin'. great! perfect! exactly what I was hoping fo- *something sqeaks* *mark's breath catches*
*mark squeals* Bye! I don't want any, I don't want any. I hate this!
*some kind of electric noise* *Mark yells* ohhh, nooo!
I don't like bad (?) - that's bad, I'mma take picture of you *mark yells again.
*mark sings this* There's nothing in the hallway, okay, there's something in the hallway *chuckles*
All right, why am I doing this? Why are you here? Why why would I do this? Why would I do this?
I don't want to do this
*loud suspenseful music* what's there? what's there? who's there?
okay, nothin'; whole lotta nothin'.
Just a whole lotta nothin'!
a little weird
All right
*mark mumbles* dark.
Dark. DARK! DARK! *to painting* Hi hello, how are you?
*to missing painting* Oh, hello.
Uh, okay? No nothin . . . Wha- *chuckles*
I don't know what you want from me there used to- woo, hey oh
All right, how 'bout you? When did I - oh? (Luca): I might want to look around for something else first?
Wait, what do you mean *mark babbles* I wanna look? Why are you so calm?
*reads box* Say10 shipping. *finished reading box* I don't want- oh . . .
When did you get back to normal? You *mark stutters* ass bag
Okay. . . all right
Ooh, I got a nail! I don't know why I have a nail, but I got a nail
Oh, do I need a nail to be able to hang this thing up there?
*mark starts screaming* Okay, I'm taking a picture of you
Holy shit!
Well, I took a picture
*angrily* I see nothing!
I'm a fool. I'm a goddamn fool, and you scared the piss out of me, but you - asshole, you asshole,
you asshole!
Okay, all right. Let me put a nail - ohhh.
Let me put a nail
*quietly*  -in this bad boy...
Yep there we go, kerchung, just like that
Yeah, baby, just like that- ooh, yeah, that looks good. Gramps, you've never looked better real proud of you
real proud of you. *strange noise*
*mark mumbling* well, that's a thing that happened.
Okay, so what do I do about that? What's the point? What's the point of hanging this up?
Oh, maybe I should take a picture of it now?
*mark mumbles* probably. *loud shattering noise*
*Mark yells* Ah? Oh, I'm sorry. You don't point that finger at me, sonny jim whoo
*laughs* That's not good. That's not good
That is not good. Don't point your dirty finger at me, or are you warning me?
*Mark squeals* Ohhhhh
Uh-oh
Okay about the key
*scared laugh*
Okay all right oh
*Mark yells*
Noooo! Ahh!
That was so good. *pretends to cry*
Ah, that was so good! That was so good! It was terrifying. I crapped my pants . . .
Ah, man that was good. Well that was the demo for Madison
I'm gonna follow up on this, this game needs - this game needs some because this game was full of scary and spooky
And I loved it so. . . Let me know what you thought everybody down the comments below
Thank you everybody so much for watching if you got other horror games you want me to play. Let me know down in the comments
Thanks again, and as always
I will see you
in the next video, bye bye!